Speaker 1: . This should really come as absolutely
no surprise to any of us. But the leading
Republican governor, a gubernatorial recall
candidate in the California gubernatorial recall,
is not saying he will accept the results and
in fact, seems to have already conceded defeat
and has launched an initiative to say that
we need to recount or something like that.
The Daily Beast is reporting Larry Elder
preemptively concedes defeat and launches
a voter fraud site before the results of today's
California gubernatorial recall have even come in.
Top polling Republican candidate Larry Elder
appeared to be already conceding defeat on Monday
and preparing to blame his loss on baseless claims
of widespread voter fraud. As first reported by
the Sacramento Bee, Elder's campaign launched
a Web site calling for his supporters to report
incidents of voter fraud and sign a petition
to investigate the results. Wait, hold on.
You're calling for an investigation
before the results are out.
The site, which is paid for by the campaign,
includes language that assumes Governor Newsom
has already won, although no results have yet been
released and Elder is campaigning. The site says,
quote, We implore you to join us in this fight as
you are able, primarily by signing our petition,
demanding a special session of the California
legislature to investigate and ameliorate the
twisted results of this recall. What we don't have
the results yet. You're calling for a four for
some kind of investigation of the results
that we don't yet have. It goes on to say,
Additionally, the website states statistical
analyzes used to detect fraud in elections held
in third world. Nations such as Russia, Venezuela
and Iran have detected fraud in California,
resulting in Governor Newsom being reinstated
as governor, by the way, reinstated. He was
never removed. It's all crazy and it really
shouldn't surprise us. Here was Larry Elder
yesterday being asked multiple times, will you
commit to accepting the results? And he won't
say that he will because he obviously will not.
Speaker 2: Larry Elder, the leading Republican
candidate, would not commit to accepting
the results of the election. Yeah.
Again, whether or not you win or lose, will you
accept the results of the election tomorrow? No,
I think we all ought to be looking at election
integrity, no matter whether you're a Democrat,
an independent or Republican. Let's all make
sure that the election is a fair election. So
this all work together no matter.
Speaker 1: Do you have any reason
to believe that it is not fair? As of right now,
do you have any evidence what
Speaker 2: the results are to
make sure that the results are valid and
legitimate and everybody who voted should
have voted? Let's all do that together. Is that a
commitment to accept the results of the election
tomorrow? I'll do that together. Let's all
work together on both sides of the aisle to
make sure that the election is a fair election.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I would like to see the actual
question. Is there anything right now that you
can point to that makes you doubt the integrity
of this election? Donald Trump? I mean, it
shouldn't surprise us. Larry Elder is doing this.
I played for you this clip last week. Donald
Trump on Newsmax is already saying it's rigged
in California as the polling has done
more and more in favor of Gavin Newsom.
The claims of rigging have increased.
Speaker 2: Got the recall election coming up
in less than a week. It's actually happening as
we speak. The polls appear to show Newsom looks
safer at this point. Larry Elder is the man
that could take it from him. What do you think
happens in California?
Speaker 5: Yeah,
well, it's probably rigged. They're sending
out all ballots. All the ballots are, you know,
mail out mail in ballots. In fact, I
guess you even have a case where you
can make your own ballot. When that happens in
Speaker 1: crayon, you can make your own ballot.
Speaker 5: Nobody's going to win except
these Democrats. So, you know, look,
they're very good. The one thing they're good at
is rigging elections. So I predict it's a rigged
election. Let's see how it turns out.
Speaker 1: So there is, of course,
no evidence of that whatsoever. But they are
already claiming fraud, already claiming fraud.
Let's hope that Larry Elder does not become
the governor of California. It would be a
real tragedy. I see it as a partial referendum on
Trump ism elder, a big pro Trump guy, big, big pro
Trump guy. And keeping Newsom would not only be
better for California than putting in Larry Elder,
who says there should be no minimum wage. He
I mean, listen, I can't we went through the
whole list on a stream yesterday and has said
he would end any kind of mass requirements, any
kind of vaccine requirements and everything. And
Trump's great. Let's hope that that doesn't happen
tonight. You can join me live on YouTube, Twitch
and Facebook for results from California tonight